[MUSIC PLAYING]
KERRY ANN KING: Steve
is going to talk
to us about the new
super power for women--
self-defense for women.
Go ahead and have a seat.
So I wanted to bring up
the first thing right away.
Self-defense for women.
I think one of the things that
I really got out of the book
was your attitude
towards this is really
about protecting women, partly
from your own experience
as a law enforcement officer but
also from your own experience
as a young man.
And I thought that that
was really an interesting--
because I think as a woman
it's easy to say, oh, well, I
have intuition, great.
Men are strong, and
women are intuitive,
and we're going to be
victims, and men are not.
But I think part of what
was interesting to me,
and really moving
in reading the book,
was that you, in fact,
had had an experience that
made sexual assault something
that you could empathize with.
STEVE KARDIAN: Yeah, when
I was in eighth grade,
I was playing on a
recreation football team.
And I ended up breaking my back,
and I ended up in the hospital.
And while I was in the
hospital, I was bedridden.
I couldn't do anything.
And about the fourth day
in, a priest came in,
and he introduced himself.
And I was a practicing
Catholic at the time.
He asked me if I wanted to--
some small chat.
And then he said, would you
like to give confession, my son?
When I tell people, it
almost sounds like a joke.
And I said, sure, so
I gave him confession.
I don't remember
exactly what I said.
And then towards or at basically
when I thought I was done,
he looks to me, and he
says, just like this,
I remember clearly.
He says, "Steven,
do you masturbate?"
And as a 14-year-old boy,
and this being a priest--
priests were God back then--
I knew that there
was something really,
really wrong with that
question, especially the way
that he said it.
So I thought I was being clever.
I said, I don't even
know what that is.
And he asks me, your
back is broken, Steven?
And I said, yes.
And so he puts the Bible
down, and he pulls down
the covers of the bed sheets.
And then he pulls down
my pajamas and underwear,
and he lifts my
member off my belly.
And he says, it's when
you play with this,
looking straight into my eyes.
And I have no idea if it
was 5 seconds, 10 seconds,
something spooked
him, whether it
was the nurses out in the hall.
And he put me back down and
grabbed his Bible, and he left.
And my best friend came in.
And I told him, I
said, Sal, you're not
going to believe what happened.
And he said, we have
to tell your parents.
I said, I know we do.
Because what they would
do, they'd drop him off.
He'd run up, and they'd come up.
So they came up,
and we told them.
And the police were called,
the hospital administrators
were called.
And they were around my bed,
and they were interviewing me,
and they were asking me
all sorts of questions.
And the police officer says
to the doctor, he says,
hey, doc, is he on medication?
Again, we had a much different
vision of priests back then.
So the doc kind
of looks, he goes,
well, he was on medication
when he came in,
but he's not on it anymore.
So the doctor looks at
me and goes, Steven,
could this have been a dream?
And right then and there,
even me as a 14-year-old kid,
especially my parents,
they were like, done.
That was a really
horrific event compared
to people that are true
survivors that have
gone through way more horrific.
That just showed me that there
are people above you in higher
places that certainly
don't have a problem taking
advantage of-- he did it to
me, he did it to many others.
Back then, it was really
difficult to track
that sort of stuff.
That's way over the years
the priesthood was really
discovered as to
what they were doing.
And I've done 1,000
media interviews.
I haven't told that.
I waited for it to be
included in the book.
KERRY ANN KING: And that was
one of the things that really
moved me about reading the book,
was Steve is coming at this not
from the perspective of
someone who's coming to tell us
how to take care of
ourselves, but someone who's
really interested and has the
experience of what it feels
like to be powerless,
and wants women,
who are more likely to be
victimized, to be empowered.
And that, I thought, was
really a wonderful thing
about the book.
Having said that, a lot of what
we're going to talk about today
also applies to all genders.
My two sons and one
daughter are here today
because I felt like
the information was
important enough, and that
it applies to everyone.
So let's talk about
situational awareness.
This is something that you get
right into at the beginning
of the book, and
today that I realized
I was really bad at
when I started reading.
Tell us a little bit
about the importance
of situational awareness.
STEVE KARDIAN: We're
in a digital age today.
We're on our mobile devices.
They're attached to our hands.
We're listening to
music in our ear buds.
And the predator utilizes--
a huge part of his game is
the element of surprise.
So if we remove that
from him, first of all,
if you even present
as a hard target,
he's likely going
to go elsewhere.
I've done social
experiments on television
where I've actually shown how
the predator would compromise
someone.
But by employing
situational awareness,
you walk into a building,
look to the left or right.
You walk out of a building,
Everything has a baseline.
You're looking for
something that's
outside of that baseline.
When you walk into a mall
with today, active shooters,
you want to know
where the exits are.
Because when things go
bad, that is not the time
to create a plan of action.
KERRY ANN KING: You used one
of the phrases that is really
useful in the book as well.
Hard target versus soft target.
What's a hard target,
what's a soft target?
STEVE KARDIAN: A soft target,
actually, years ago, there
was the Grayson, Stein study.
And they took video footage of
people walking down a Manhattan
street, and they took it to
these hardened criminals--
murderers, rapists, killers--
and they showed them the video.
And they said, what do
you see in terms of people
that you would try
to take advantage of.
They let petite women, petite
men, older seniors, men
and women walk by.
But they were looking
at particular traits
in terms of their gait,
their posture, their stride.
And they all, independently
of one another,
identified those
particular traits
where they identified--
everyone independent chose
the same people as soft targets.
So when I did a social
experiment with Inside Edition,
I went on to a college campus,
and I watched the young women
coming out of the
classroom building.
And I was looking for the
women that were texting.
I was looking for the women
that were on the cell phone.
I was looking for the women that
were looking at their notes.
I was looking for the women
that were eating their lunch
and saying, oh my god, it's a
beautiful day, I'm out of here.
The women that came out and
scanned the parking lot,
saw me, maybe didn't see me,
but were walking assertively,
with a purpose, I let them go.
And I targeted the women
that were preoccupied.
That preoccupation,
when you're surprised,
you are that much more
vulnerable, if you will.
So it was a social experiment.
Every girl, all
eight of the women
that I targeted for
being soft targets,
allowed me in their car
and drove off with me.
And it was a segment to show
are college students really
trusting.
Are we really trusting
when we're out and about
in a comfortable
environment, which
would be the college campus.
KERRY ANN KING: So this
is really interesting
because the distraction is
one thing that I got out
of the book.
I realized that I'm that woman
who gets to the subway station,
puts her bag on the
ground, and starts digging
for her metro card.
I stopped doing that right away.
But distraction is definitely
a factor, and cell phones.
There's a big
distraction that I notice
when I'm out and about in the
evening in particular, which
is alcohol for young women.
And that's something you
also talk about in the book,
because people drink
a lot these days,
and drinking is a big
part of socializing.
And you talk about
how to go out but not
turn yourself into a soft
target because you're
out to have a good time.
STEVE KARDIAN: Well, a
lot of the sexual assaults
that we see that are
perpetrated on college campuses,
in nightclubs, they
involve alcohol by one
or both-- usually both parties.
And it's a neurotoxin, and
it changes your behavior
to some degree.
It lowers your inhibitions.
It makes you less
able to mentally
be able to deal with the
situation, and physically,
because of the neurotoxin.
Everything slows down.
Your thought process.
God forbid if you did
have to fight back,
you are now 20%, 30%, 40%
less efficient and effective
to deal with someone that
means to compromise you.
KERRY ANN KING: Exactly.
So we have these multiple
distractions now.
I was thinking about your book.
I was walking down the street
and saw three young women, one
of whom could barely stand up.
And it occurred to me that
one who could barely stand up
was lucky her
friends were sober.
That's one thing you
talk about in the book,
is safety in numbers.
STEVE KARDIAN: Yeah, we
advocate go out as a group,
go home as a group.
But we also are
realists, and knowing
that, in the perfect
world, that will happen.
If you go out as a group,
and one of the girls
wants to leave early, or one of
the girls wants to stay late,
or maybe she met someone
that she's interested in,
and she wants to
hang out with them,
you've got to deal with that.
And so in the book, I
give step-by-step things
that you can do on how to best
depart from that situation.
Like some people, oh, we're
going to go out as a group.
But man, you walk
into this place,
and you just get that
feeling things are not good.
You want to get out of there
because the longer you stay,
it's going to get better.
The environment will
likely get worse.
Whether it's a club,
or a frat house,
or a party among
friends, there's
many things that could go wrong.
That first feeling you get,
if you walk in and you say,
I really don't belong here, you
want to follow that feeling.
KERRY ANN KING: And
that's something
that I think is another
important takeaway
from the book, is allowing
your body to tell you
what's going on.
You talk about how that
gut feeling is actually
a real, physical sensation
that you can listen to.
STEVE KARDIAN: Yeah, I've
had it over the years
in law enforcement
so many times.
My first experience was at 17.
Long story short,
I saved the life
of a child that was
buried in the sand when
20 adults stood around and
just stood there, frozen.
And I was going to walk 15
minutes away to a place called
Indian Town in Old Saybrook.
I went five minutes, I had
this overwhelming feeling
that I had to turn back.
And I convinced my
girlfriend-now-wife
that we've got to go back.
And if I hadn't gone back,
this young 8-year-old boy
would have died.
KERRY ANN KING: I think one
of the things you talk about,
though, is how women
are socialized to ignore
some of their gut feelings.
We're taught to be
nice, we're taught
to be helpful, we're
taught to be polite,
and how that's not necessarily
the best thing for us to do.
STEVE KARDIAN: You ought to meet
some of the female cops I've
worked with.
They have amazing intuition.
But in general, in some
homes, some families,
you're brought up in such a
way as to kind of put your--
statistics show that it's 50/50.
I believe women have the
greater gift of intuition,
but often they're
apt to put it aside.
In all the social experiments
that I did, 21 out of 21 women,
they all said, I knew
something wasn't right,
but I'm the team leader,
I wanted to help.
So they have that feeling,
but they sometimes
don't listen to it.
So it's important.
It could be a sense
of foreboding.
It could be a tickle in your
belly, that gut feeling,
they say.
It could be a lump
in your throat.
It could be a little tingle
in your chest, the hair rising
on the back of your neck.
Because every woman
that I've ever
dealt with in the history
of my law enforcement,
when they were
encountered personally
by someone that meant
them an ill intent,
they had that feeling.
They knew something
wasn't right.
And if we listen to that,
the only thing intuition
will do you wrong is
you will disregard it.
If you listen to it,
it will never harm you.
KERRY ANN KING: Yeah,
that's really interesting.
How many people here have
had that sense of foreboding
and kept going with
whatever you thought?
Oh, but he's really cute.
Oh, but she's a little old
lady, she can't possibly
have anything against me.
Why would she?
And I think that that's one of
the key takeaways from reading
the book, is really
allowing yourself
to listen to that little
voice in your head.
But then one of
the things that I
think we tend to do in
our desire to be nice
is be afraid that we
are judging people.
And what occurred to me
as I was reading the book
was really the idea
of racial profiling.
I think particularly for
young women out on their own,
not wanting to judge someone
based on the way they're
dressed, or their race, or their
ethnicity, we tend to be like,
oh, I don't want to think that.
And is there a way
that you can kind of
understand that that's not
where you're doing versus maybe
when you might be doing it?
STEVE KARDIAN: Well, if you
have that uncomfortable feeling,
and there's certain
pre-indicators of behavior
that people will do when
they're targeting you.
For example, recently I did some
interviewing on subway groping.
And all these women that
had been subway groped,
they were like, did
that just happen?
No, can't be, did
it just happen.
I think he did.
And so they debate amongst
themselves as to what it is.
If someone, regardless
of whether they're
in a business suit, or they're a
blue collar, it doesn't matter.
If they give you that feeling
that you don't belong there,
particularly with them.
You might have a
target glance, somebody
that wants to maybe
steal something for,
and he sees-- oh, look
at that gold bracelet.
It's called a target glance.
He's looking at that
because he wants it.
It's like in law enforcement,
if he looks at my gun,
he wants to go for my gun.
He looks at the doors
and the windows,
it's likely he wants to escape.
So people subconsciously
will do things
that will put you on notice.
And you may not know why, but
you'll say, I just don't feel--
you're talking to
yourself, of course.
our internal subconscious
is about 80%.
So we have dialogue with
ourselves all day long.
We are assessing, look at
that person over there,
but we're talking to ourselves.
So listen to that inner voice.
It's very powerful.
KERRY ANN KING: So you
mentioned that target glance.
Are there any other
things that a woman
should look for in
a person, regardless
of how they're dressed
or who they happen to be,
that should put you on notice?
STEVE KARDIAN: We refer to it
as "keep your head on a swivel
and watch your six."
So as you're going,
you're just glancing.
And if you happen
to see something,
maybe somebody's watching you.
Maybe he's off on the sidewalk,
or a little bit excreted,
or you're in that
subway and he's
waiting sort of in the back
because you'll pull out
a couple of dollars,
and he'll want
to give you his bogus subway
token, which has nothing on it,
for like $2 so you save $1.
You notice that by
target glancing.
When you're walking by someone,
it's OK to put them on notice.
You don't have to
look at them, but you
sort of glance this way.
And a lot of people,
when they feel
intimidated, they feel that
someone is targeting them,
they feel that someone
is maybe watching them
for whatever purpose,
they might do this,
or they might look away.
But you get into the habit,
keep your head on a level
where you'll look this way,
and you just keep walking.
That's the sign
of a hard target.
If you were to stalking
me out, watching me,
and I looked, and I went
kind of like this, that's
the sign that I'm intimidated.
Or if I looked away, that's
a sign that I'm intimidated.
So we get into the habit.
You can practice it.
Just look at somebody
randomly for a half a second,
and just bring your
head back on a level.
That's a sign of a hard target.
That's a sign of strength.
Taking away the element
of surprise from someone
takes away 70% of someone
that wishes you bad instead.
KERRY ANN KING: And
that was really key,
the idea that you create a
blueprint for these situations.
STEVE KARDIAN: When I saved
that kid on the beach,
I had read a pamphlet
about rescue breathing.
None of the adults on that
beach knew what to do.
I read a pamphlet a
month before vividly,
and I was able to perform
and save his life.
So when you think
about something
could go wrong--
somebody's breaking
into your dorm, your apartment,
your house, and what do I do?
Your heart rate goes
up to 175 beats.
You go into the frozen zone.
At 115 beats, you lose your
fine motor skills, your ability
to dial.
I've seen men and women
not be able to dial 911.
Upwards towards 135, 145,
you lose your complex,
which are a lot of what
martial art programs teach.
Our program at 145 to
175 thrives because we
use gross motor skills.
Our big, stronger muscles.
But if you don't
have a plan, you're
more apt to panic and
not know what to do.
So by creating
that plan, thinking
about something that could
go wrong in your life,
come up with a solution.
Think about it vividly.
In law enforcement, we
call it visualization.
The military calls it
emergency conditioning,
and we use it very,
very effectively.
Thank God I've never
had to use my weapon.
I've never had to shoot anybody.
But in my mind, I've gone
through thousands and thousands
and thousands of
scenarios so that there
would be no gray line
where I had to save my life
or the life of the third person.
KERRY ANN KING: And
that's one thing
I would say about
reading the book.
Not all of what
you'll read in here
will be easy to read,
especially as someone
who has been a victim.
There were a couple of
things that I read here
and it was like, wow,
that's what happened to me.
And it was not easy to read.
But I think one of the
benefits of reading
about it is that that's
another opportunity to rehearse
without being in the situation.
So, just because we
talked about it before,
anybody take our boxing class?
I know Lauren does.
What's the difference
between what
you teach and, say, what
Josh or Xavier teaches
people in our boxing classes?
STEVE KARDIAN: For women?
KERRY ANN KING: Yes,
in terms of defense.
STEVE KARDIAN: We started
20-something years ago.
We had a group of
survivors-- sexual assault,
domestic violence,
kidnapping, date rape drugs--
and they asked us to
put together a program.
So my partner, Brad
Parker in Phoenix,
Arizona, long-time martial
artist, boxer, karate guy,
began teaching them some really
cool martial art techniques.
And he found out
quickly two things.
They couldn't retain
the technique.
New people couldn't retain
the technique in a 45
to 60-minute class.
And number two, he was teaching
them how to fight like a man.
Now, if you teach a woman
to fight like a man,
and she goes up against a man
who typically, in that dynamic,
through evolution, men
typically are bigger, stronger,
more pain tolerant.
Men have a reptilian brain.
If you've ever seen a real
street fight, guy punches,
guy punches back.
Guy kicks, guy kicks back.
Guy bites, guy bites back.
So it's telegraphing.
And I see it in
the police academy.
If you've never been
punched in the head,
it's like a lightning bolt
going through your head,
and it can take all
the fight out of you.
So he began reversing
that process
and teaching him how to
fight like a woman using
their bigger, stronger,
more powerful weapons
against a man's more
vulnerable points,
putting them in the positions
that they found themselves in.
And we were talking earlier
about high-level martial
artists that I have
done investigations
on that their martial
art didn't work
against their non-martial art
acquaintance or boyfriend.
And it's devastating to them.
The dynamic of a
sexual assault, you're
going to be grabbed
and taken somewhere,
or you're going to be grabbed
and brought down to the ground.
Say the intent was right now,
it would be within five seconds
that he would be trying
to get you to the ground.
If you're taken from point A
to point B and it's a stranger,
in the 90th percentile, you're
just not going to come back.
It's unforgiving.
So we do that
preventative aspect.
Don't ever let yourself be
taken from here to there.
The guy says, "Do what
I say or I'll kill you.
Don't scream."
You scream.
"Don't run."
You run.
He can't harm you there.
He can't kill you.
He doesn't want to
kill, he doesn't
want to sexually assault
you, harm you in some way.
He wants to get you to
the secondary location.
So by fighting back, your
value to him as a soft target
diminishes.
So he would rather
move on elsewhere
because he relies on the
compliant fear factor
that what he says will
get you to do what he
wants you to do through fear.
Or he may say something
like, if you do what I say,
everything will be OK.
And you'll want to believe that,
but the end result is horrific.
KERRY ANN KING: So
then the techniques
that you're talking about are
ones that can extricate you
quickly, and also I
think empower you to feel
like you can do something.
And I think I'll just say,
from personal experience,
I have a lot of karate training.
I've done a lot of boxing.
Taught kickboxing.
The last time I
was in a situation
where I would have thought all
of that would have applied,
none of it applied because
I had no rehearsal.
Yeah, I could kick
someone in the head,
but kicking them in the head was
not going to be the solution.
So having lots of
fancy Taekwondo skills
doesn't necessarily translate.
STEVE KARDIAN: You might
kick the guy's butt,
but your objective is to change
his behavior enough so that you
can escape the situation.
I've been knocked out by girls
90 pounds when I wore the suit.
Kicking through the suit
knocked me out unconscious
because of the ground is
their base, kicking up-- it's
called an upkick.
Actually, it's illegal in
UFC, or Ultimate Fighting
Championship, where they
kick up from the ground,
and his targets are
much more accessible.
So again, you might
kick his butt.
Your objective--
change his behavior
so you've got three,
four, or five seconds
to escape the
situation, if you will.
KERRY ANN KING: Last thing.
I would like to hear
five things a woman can
do when she leaves this room
to not be a soft target.
STEVE KARDIAN: Employ
situational awareness.
Take in your environment.
I mentioned that
everything has a baseline.
You're looking for things that
are a little bit off baseline.
The baseline in New York City
is different than the baseline
in a small suburb in Tennessee.
However, regardless of where you
are, if you drop your guard low
enough, there would be--
could be-- someone there
to take advantage of you.
Believe in that gut feeling.
Let that intuitive
process be a guide.
Get in touch with it.
People watch.
I go into a restaurant,
my back is to the wall,
and I'm watching
people, and I'm trying
to figure out is he having
a good day, or a bad day,
or what does she do
for a living, what
does he do for a living.
Or a family,
they're interacting.
And I say, I wonder
what their conversation
is by looking at their
facial expressions.
Learn some self-defense.
Create that blueprint.
Think of something bad happens
to somebody in your family,
or a friend, or in the media.
Think about what would
I do in that situation.
Or you're on the subway, and you
see somebody hassling somebody,
and he's not leaving them alone.
Well, start to think,
what would I do?
How would I handle that?
And come up with a
solution to a problem,
because when it
really happens, you'll
never have the opportunity
to create a plan of action
like you would prior.
So if we examine it, think
about it, we create a file.
Your brain doesn't
know if you've lived it
or if you've thought
about it vividly.
It creates a file
as if you have.
KERRY ANN KING: Awesome.
And if you're like
me, make sure you
know where your metro card is
when you get to the subway.
OK, awesome.
[APPLAUSE]